lassen sie uns über ein großes
wirtschaftsprojekt sprechen nord stream
2 umso mehr in der kritik natürlich nach
der vergiftung neuwahlen wie es die
dessen spuren und eindeutig nach
russland und dort in die regierung führt
nun gibt es in ihrer partei wichtige
stimmen die trotzdem sagen wir dürfen
das projekt auf keinen fall beenden ich
fliege sogar auf jeden fall im dezember
nach moskau und treffe mich mit dem
putin sagt sachsens ministerpräsident
kretschmann
was antworten sie ich schätze michael
kretschmer persönlich sehr
ich bin in dieser frage anderer meinung
wobei ist im prinzip immer richtig ist
dass wir miteinander reden
die frage ist nur was sagen wir da und
was tun wir da und nachdem nun dieser
erneute giftanschlag offensichtlich auf
russische quellen zurückzuführen ist
russland sich jedenfalls an der
aufklärung überhaupt nicht beteiligt
wie aber sehr starke hinweise darauf
haben dass ohne beteiligung russischer
stellen solche giftgas anschläge
giftanschläge gar nicht möglich wären
muss ich sagen ist der punkt gekommen wo
man jetzt doch mal die frage stellen
muss ob wir alles so weitermachen können
wie bisher die frage schon zwei eine
komplexe geschichte zur zeit müssen die
dänen darüber entscheiden ob weiter
gebaut wird oder nicht weil es durch
dänisches hoheitsgewässer geht im grunde
genommen das ist aber auch jetzt zu spät
darüber nochmal neu nachzudenken jetzt
die sekunde vertiefen wir gleich aber
lassen die sekunde bei hin kretschmer
bleiben besuch jetzt in moskau
ankündigen und zu sagen man dürfe jetzt
die eskalation nicht weitertreiben die
eskalation die er bedeutete ja navalny
zu vergiften
wie stehen sie das also von deutschland
und von europa geht keine eskalation aus
sondern sie herrn putin jetzt diese
eskalation geht zurzeit ausschließlich
von russland aus und ob ich einen besuch
machen würde oder nicht darüber müsste
ich nachdenken
jedenfalls geht es jetzt nicht
unkritisch einfach so weiter wie bisher
ich habe den vorschlag gemacht ein
zweijähriges moratorium über diese
pipeline und dann vernünftig reden und
versuchen wieder eine lösung zu finden
aber das setzt voraus dass wir uns auf
der europäischen seite einig sind wir
sind uns leider ja noch nicht einmal in
deutschland einig ist dass besonders
konsequenten moratorium zu fordern oder
ist das so ein bisschen kompromiss weil
man sich nicht recht entscheiden kann
zwischen dem einen und dem anderen bei
zwei jahre einzufrieren und dann weiter
zu bauen herr wissen ja weise die
politik besteht häufig aus kompromissen
und es wäre auch jemals so wie der
einzelne sich tasten und gerne wünscht
es gibt viele die sagen abbrechen
also nehmen sie die grünen die alle der
meinung sind sofort abbrechen
es gibt viele die sagen das geht auch
aus juristischen gründen überhaupt nicht
wir müssen sie in jedem fall auch aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen weiterbauen
ich glaube aus wirtschaftlichen gründen
brauchen wir sie im augenblick nicht die
gasversorgung europas ist gesichert wir
brauchen nicht diese zweite pipeline
durch die ostsee
aber wir werden sie irgendwann
wahrscheinlich zu ende bauen wollen
vielleicht auch müssen aber so ganz
einfach zur tagesordnung überzugehen
finde ich geht auch nicht und deswegen
habe ich diesen vorschlag gemacht